sous une robe sûr sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé belge à sita quand co sera
notre invité nous évoquerons avec elle
la place des femmes en europe et
notamment dans les entreprises le droit
à l'avortement dans une majorité de pays
de l'union européenne il est légal sans
condition même si les anti ivg ont
parfois entendre leur voix nous verrons
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins les
superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera aujourd'hui au chiffre 13
zone europe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui à sita kango
bonjour moins chaud alors vous êtes
eurodéputés belges vice présidente du
groupe des conservateurs et réformistes
européens membres de la commission des
libertés civiles de la justice et des
affaires intérieures et de la
sous-commission droits de l'homme alors
ensemble on va parler aujourd'hui des
femmes en europe et notamment des femmes
en entreprise
d'ici cet été on comptera trois femmes
seulement on peut on peut le regretter à
la tête d'un groupe du cac 40 alors
qu'est-ce que ça déjà ça vous inspire
mais ça c'est pas quelque chose qui est
nouveau pour moi je me suis toujours
battu pour l'intégration des femmes en
politique et en entreprise je viens
moi-même du monde des affaires et j'ai
organisé des événements et que des
livres sur le sujet donc ce que ça
m'inspire c'est que les femmes doivent
toujours prendre leur place et ne
doivent pas attendre la permission des
hommes jamais dans les relances de plus
en plus ça n'arrivera jamais parce que
il ya cette expression anglaise connue
qui dirigent nos salles chinoises et
free lunch donc il n'y a rien de honteux
que le pouvoir n'est pas gratuit donc
votre place il faut la conquérir il faut
la prendre c'est ce que les hommes ont
fait aussi et tout leaf les trois femmes
qui sont arrivés ben non pas logicielle
gratuite mais c'était un catherine
mcgregor à la tête de angie depuis début
2000 21 christelle heidemann qui va
prendre la tête de orange à partir du 4
avril estelle brachlianoff qui va
prendre la tête de veolia à partir du
1er juillet et on a un mois j'ai lu
aussi qu'en france dans les causses à
l'administration en général il ya quand
même 45 % 2 deux femmes donc c'est mieux
quand je pense à fait c'est dommage
qu'on parle des forts je pense que ça
devrait être naturel que les femmes
fassent partie de la gestion du pouvoir
politique économique et aussi dans leur
vie intime parce que c'est qu'on voit là
c'est le symptôme d'un problème dans la
société et j'ai écrit dans un de mes
livres que le péché originel se retrouve
dans la répartition classique déroule
donc l'homme qui est allé gagner de
l'argent je crois que ce n'est pas
seulement la faute de l'homme en tout
cas moi par exemple j'ai toujours pris
ma place parmi les 4 fin je me suis
jamais laissé faire et au sein du
parlement je prends ma place aussi je
pense qu'il faut se battre il faut pas
baisser les bras il faut pas mentir non
plus aux gens en disant mais écoutez
attendait quelqu'un va vous le donner ça
ne s'analyse pas comme ça il faut
vraiment travailler dur il faut savoir
dire écoutez je vais pas être la seule à
m'occuper des enfants dont il faut se
battre à la maison aussi ou alors mais
bien choisir son compagnon il ya là un
des patrons de fait d'être co dirigeant
de facebook sheryl sandberg qui a écrit
dans son livre line in donc prenez votre
place elle a écrit un de vos choix de
carrière les plus importants en tant que
femme c'est le choix de votre conjoint
d'au moins un mec qui veut pas que je
fasse mon boulot ou que je vais
poursuivre mes ambitions avec autant de
passion que lui il a pas de place dans
ma vie alors on ici au parlement
européen à bruxelles alors au parlement
européen la parité est plutôt respectée
en tout cas au niveau des eurodéputés la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen veut davantage de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration en général c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure elle veut
garantir un quota de genre plus de 40%
dans les conseils d'administration des
entreprises cotées en bourse est-ce que
vous pensez que les quotas c'est une
bonne chose moi j'allais penser à un
moment donné il ya 15 ans avant moi même
d'arriver dans un conseil
d'administration et d'être élu dans un
poste à responsabilité en politique et
donc je me rends compte en y
réfléchissant qu'il faut aussi dans la
poursuite de ce qu'on veut atteindre on
apprend également à survivre il faut se
faire respecter et occuper la place en
même temps que les autres savoir faire
entendre sa voix et donc ce que je
constate c'est que font des layènes en
fait mon femme ce qu'elle dit c'est un
énorme mensonge
et c'est une fausse promesse c'est
également
je dirais une fausse réponse un vrai
problème est ce que nous voulons tous
qu'il y ait un équilibre au niveau des
sites du pouvoir est ce que c'est utile
est bon pour la société oui les femmes
ont autant de talent que les hommes mais
est-ce que sa solution d'imposer un
quota aux entreprises cotées est une
solution réaliste et même efficace non
c'est un gros mensonge la démagogie
c'est absolument des mots magiques
démagogique et ce qui est triste c'est
qu'elle ment aux femmes en disant ça
pourquoi elle même elle est une maman 1
elle est ministre elle s'est battue en
politique à quel moment de sa vie
professionnelle at-elle reçu un cadeau
dont il faut dire la vérité moi si les
jeunes filles viennent me trouver au
parlement en disant si tu as comment tu
as fait pour être élu comment un script
en sort tous les jours comment tu as
réussi à te faire respecter dans son
groupe politique à t'imposer dans la
politique est un millième machisme aussi
je le vis alors je le dis je me suis
battu si quelqu'un me donne un coup de
poing je le lui rend un essai pas
littéralement bien sûr mais il faut pas
se laisser faire faut pas se laisser
faire je leur dis la vérité je ne sais
parfois pas comment gérer je suis une
maman et parfois je me suis retrouvé en
larmes dans ma voiture parce que j'étais
trop j'étais en retard à la crèche par
exemple que je me sentais coupable
aujourd'hui encore je me demande je suis
prêt je me sens coupable quand je suis à
la maison parce que je n'ai peut-être
pas fini un truc au boulot je me sens
coupable quand je suis ici parce que bon
j'aimerais bien battre ma fille tout le
monde à ce conflit intérieur mais
comment est ce que je fais je cherche
des solutions j'en discute avec mon
enfant et donc il faut partager ce
secret de ce qu'on fait pour s'en sortir
pour que les gens puissent savoir
qu'elle ferait prendre mais si on les
remet en dix ans mais reste dans ton
coin reste bien dans ton fauteuil le
quota viendra et puis on remettra le
pouvoir dans le bec ça n'arrive pas et
vous pensez-vous avoir élu à la tête du
parlement européen une femme c'est un
message fort répondu je dirais qu'on a
élu une femme compétente et une femme
qui a qui a la rage de gagner qui a la
rage de gagner qui s'est battue qui a
voulu un et donc le matin mais cela que
je connais bien parce qu'on a travaillé
ensemble dans libé est là cette passion
et cette volonté mais il y aura toujours
des gens qui vous diront soyez patients
c'est pas votre moment attendez de moi
aussi j'ai entendu des choses comme ça à
mes besoins on dépassera jamais nous il
faut pas attendre il faut surtout faire
le contraire est évidemment que vous
allez avoir peur mais quand vous avez
peur ce que vous attendez de votre zone
de confort alors moi je dirais il faut
foncer il faut foncer à ce moment là
justement vous parlez vous parlez peur
il ya un autre point qui voudrait que on
aborde ensemble sa situation des femmes
en afghanistan
nous avons reçu en septembre dernier
pour parler de ce sujet vous faisiez
part de vos craintes pour les femmes
afghanes sous le régime taliban mais
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire ce
qu'il en est aujourd'hui là bas ça n'a
pas changé et donc quand on voit il ya
des enfants des fillettes qui sont
vendus des
on a vu moi j'ai vu une image dans une
université où on dit ah oui c'est génial
en afghanistan les femmes peuvent
retourner à l'université mais les femmes
sont elles sont en burqa on voit mais
c'est vraiment comme si on était dans le
film là où il ya un type qui s'appelle
dark vador j'oublie toujours le triste
round voilà dans star wars sa commune de
la saos et c'est vraiment triste et on
peut même se demander si ce sont des
femmes qui sont sais pas en fait et donc
quand je vois ça sert quels sont
instrumentalisés oui elles sont
instrumentalisés deux ont les gommes on
les efface on leur refuse d'être qui
elles sont et on l'est on leur donne
elles deviennent une masse anonyme sans
volonté sans liberté il me semble que le
ministère de mystère des femmes qui
existait en afghanistan a été transformé
en ministère de la charia david heymans
la charia et on a entendu le problème
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que ce qui
se passe avec ces femmes en afghanistan
qui n'ont pas droit travaillent et qui
n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas de droit de
choisir leur mari etc et qui subit qui
n'ont même pas le droit de voyager en
taxi non accompagnés et qui doit porter
une burqa c'est ce que l'islam radical
veut partout dans le monde pour les
femmes y compris en europe dans nos
quartiers et face à cela on doit pas
être naïf 1 on doit pas être seulement
aux qualifications face à ça mais il
faut déjà éviter les tabous chaque fois
que quelqu'un critique le voile est dit
que c'est pour souligner l'infériorité
de la femme lui demander de ne pas
provoquer les hommes la rendre coupable
d'un homme la grèce sexuellement c'est
ça le projet quand on dit ça évidemment
qu'on nous demande de nous taire n'est
pas exagéré de ne pas stigmatiser mais
en réalité on abandonne les femmes à
l'islamisme et moi je trouve ça très
inquiète en encore vu le président des
verts en allemagne dire qu'il faudrait
peut-être instaurer une partie de la
charia compatible avec nos lois en
europe mais en allemand moi je suis
choqué je suis né au burkina faso dans
une famille musulmane 1 je suis allé à
la mosquée j'ai vu ça je connais les
dessous et du koro je sais ce que c'est
que l'islam mais je sais aussi qu'elle
est la partie qui est mauvaise pour les
femmes c'est à dire tous n'y a rien qui
répond pour les femmes 1 donc sinon les
hommes il peut avoir quatre femmes et
tout le bazar mais si quand je vois
quelqu'un sur le continent de simone de
beauvoir dire on va instaurer une partie
de la charia j'ai envie de dire mais
coûte instaure les sur toi-même commence
déjà par inverse les rôles tu vas être
les points tu vas être parmi les quatre
mari d'une femme qui va porter une burqa
et tu vas tu vas disponibles
sexuellement quand elle le veut et tu
pourrais jamais choisi toi même c'est
que tu feras pas le droit d'aller
travailler ou de problèmes taxi tout
seul on va voir si c'est là qu'on tend
justement en janvier dernier à une
réunion qui s'est tenu à oslo en norvège
entre des délits qu une délégation de
talibans et des diplomates européens
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est normal
est-ce qu'il faut discuter avec les
talibans est ce qu'il faut instaurer une
relation normale avec les talibans je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention de
tout on ne peut pas être radical là
dessus je pense qu'il ne faut pas
légitimer les talibans mais il faut leur
parler ça dépend maintenant de ce qu'on
va leur dire moi je moi je voudrais
qu'on leur dise qu'on ne va pas tranché
transiger sur les valeurs mais il faut
éviter devenu notre argent aux talibans
il faut le donner à la société civile et
aux femmes pour qu'elles puissent se
libérer il faut poser des conditions
strictes faut pas se laisser faire en
afghanistan faut pas se laisser faire
dans le sahel non plus ou au burkina
faso et mali il faut peut-être prendre
des sanctions qu'elles soient
économiques ou autres envers les pays
qui sont alliés des talibans puisqu'on
sait que certains pays aident les
talibans justement donc je pense que
quoi qu'on fasse il faut pas perdre de
vue que nous devons aider la population
civile nous devons les aider justement à
s'insurger la nouvelle on les a pas
assez d un acte concret on va bien quand
il ya eu le départ de kaboul penser
qu'on a laissé les populations de côté
oui on leur a dit merci
comme ça pendant tout le temps qu on a
été présent on a financé le paternalisme
et on a financé la corruption on n'a pas
financé la liberté et on a confondu
stratégie tactique donc en réalité un
avion conçu à long terme
au mali en afrique de l'ouest aussi
alors on l'a vu il ya quelques semaines
sur l'émission zone interdite qui est
diffusée envoyés sur m6 il y avait un
reportage sur l'islam radical vous avez
exprimé votre soutien à ophélie meunier
qui anime cette émission elle reçoit des
menaces de mort récurrentes depuis la
diffusion de ce sujet elle est
actuellement placé sous protection
policière
quel est votre sentiment à ce sujet un
sentiment de colère et de révolte je
trouve que c'est totalement inadmissible
quand des remparts en doivent se cacher
parce qu'on a dénoncé l' islamisme parce
qu'on agisse fait son travail de
journaliste
et en plus c'est comment l'islamisme est
en train de s'implanter en france dans
une ville française donc on n'est même
pas un afghanistan donc je dirais
aujourd'hui tout le monde devrait
condamner cela on ne peut pas accepter
on doit aller courir que c'est
extrêmement grave
donc on n'avance pas on n'aime pas
besoin d'aller en afghanistan pour voir
les islamistes qui sont ici parmi nous
et il faut pas se voiler la face très
bien merci beaucoup à sita content
d'avoir été avec nous dans une europe je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
belges vice présidente du groupe des
conservateurs et réformistes européens
membres de la commission des libertés
civiles de la justice et des affaires
intérieures et de la sous-commission
droits de l'homme
soon europe chez nos voisins
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
a choisi l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
le droit à l'avortement avec léa carmona
et chez nos voisins comment ça se passe
le droit à l'avortement l'avortement est
un acte médical visant à stopper une
grossesse pour diverses raisons par voie
médicamenteuse ou chirurgicale cette
intervention doit se faire dans un délai
fixé par la loi en france lit vie j'ai
été autorisé par la loi veil de 1975 le
délai légal d'avortement et de 12
semaines un délai qui varie selon les
circonstances comme un danger pour la
mère ou une malformation du foetus par
exemple par ailleurs les vg ainsi que
tous les actes autour de celle-ci comme
des consultations ou les échographies
sont intégralement prises en charge par
l'assurance maladie presque tous les
pays européens autorisent l interruption
volontaire de grossesse au luxembourg la
dépénalisation de l'avortement d'hadji
vernon décembre 2014 elle permet
aujourd'hui aux luxembourgeoise de
recourir à liv et j'ai dans un délai de
douze semaines après le début de la
grossesse comme en france auparavant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'était autorisé qu'en cas de détresse
en irlande l'avortement est entrée en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2019 elle
autorise les vg sans conditions jusqu'à
12 semaines et 24 semaines dans le cas
de risque pour la vie ou de graves
dangers pour la santé de la femme
enceinte en pologne l'avortement n'est
autorisé qu'en cas de viol d'inceste ou
de danger pour la mère depuis janvier
2021 après avoir tenté de l'interdire
totalement en janvier 2016 le
gouvernement l'a restreint en supprimant
la possibilité d'avorter en cas de
malformations graves du foetus qui
concernait 90 % des ivg dans le pays le
seul pays interdisant totalement et mac
quelles que soient la situation et
femmes ayant avorté ou médecin ayant
pratiqué une ivg risque jusqu'à trois
ans de prison ferme en parallèle
certains pays d'europe bénéficient d'un
délai plus long pour bâtir pour
pratiquer l'avortement pardon c'est le
cas par exemple de l'espagne où il est
praticable jusqu'à 14 semaines ou encore
au portugal où le délai s'étend jusqu'à
22 semaines
soon europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine le
terroir est à l'honneur le chef nicolas
pas cielo de la pâtisserie parisienne
cinq sens nous dévoile sa recette de la
tarte tatin center tatin elle est un peu
l à peu spécial parce que c'est une
recette que j'ai fait pour le concours
des meilleurs ouvriers de france en 2018
alors pour réaliser la pâte sucrée on
aura besoin de farine de sucre glace de
poudre d'amandes de beurre du sel et 1,9
à température ambiante c'est beaucoup
mieux parce qu'après s'il sort du frigo
il est froid ça à faire durcir la pâte
pour réaliser la crème pâtissière on
aura besoin de la crème un peu de beurre
du sucre de la vanille des bonnes gousse
de vanille fraîche
une feuille de gélatine des jaunes et 2
pour le coup de la fécule de pomme de
terre et pour finir on va réaliser un
caramel donc on aura besoin de sucre dos
on va rebaptiser ça avec un peu de fèves
de tonka
une pointe de fleur de sel et puis les
pommes forcément sans pomme vont pas
faire de tarte tatin
et ben on va commencer du coup pour
réaliser la pâte sucrée on va mettre
dans un bol la farine on va prendre le
beurre alors pas forcément pommade moi
je les sorties du frigo donc les dés
sont assez sont assez dur et ça permet
de bien sable et la pâte donc là on va
vraiment voir le mélange du beurre froid
qui ce qui ce se sable avec avec la avec
la farine c'est important de pas avoir
un beurre trop chaud après il va être
fondue sera moussa a pu se faire
un mélange crémeux là on va rester sur
quelque chose d'assez d' assez solide
alors on sait que c'est bon quand tous
les tous les morceaux de beurre sont à
peu près à la même somme près homogène
en termes de taille en fait parce qu'au
début il a des gros morceaux et tout va
ce qu'on va voir ça va vraiment donner
ces espèces de d'aspect vraiment sableux
voilà on voit bien que ça direct comme
de la poudre fait le beurre c'est bien
mélanger la farine mais n'est pas fendu
donc à ce moment là on va pouvoir
ajouter le sucre glace
et la poudre d'amandes
pour l'as mélangez le tout et puis on va
rajouter l'oeuf à température ambiante
et le sel
tout l'ensemble commencent à se mélanger
et l'oeuf donc le gras le beurre la
farine et ça ça fait plus qu'une pâte
et bien mélanger ya pas de morceaux
dedans
et ça je vais finir sur la table
donc je mets un tout petit peu de farine
sont battables hop je suis sorti on peut
voir qu'elle se travaille déjà très bien
on perd voilà je finis à la main donc là
on voit vraiment une belle pâte bien
homogène
voilà une fois qu'on a récupéré une fois
qu'on a une pâte homogène on va la
mettre au frigo pendant 30 minutes
voilà donc là maintenant je détaille
cette pâte sucrée qu'on a un peu étalé à
entre 3 et 5 mm on va là détaillé qu'un
cercle qui est un tout petit peu plus
grand que notre moule on voit assad tout
dépend la taille de votre moule il ya
toujours allez un bon centimètre deux
centimètres au dessus voilà ensuite on
va foncer le fond de tarte donc c'est à
dire qu'on va appliquer la pâte à
l'intérieur donc là l'idée c'est de
vraiment ramener la pâte dans l'angle du
fond de tarte on essaie de garder la
même épaisseur partout aulas est une
belle régularité et après une fois qu'on
est bien au fond on étale bien contre
les parois voilà je passe plusieurs fois
pour vraiment avoir une régularité donc
très bonne régularité partout on vient
mettre un coup de lame sur les bords
pour vraiment avoir une finition très
net et c'est à ce moment là qu'on peut
vraiment s'apercevoir que la l'épaisseur
elle est vraiment très nette on va juste
l'appliquer un tout petit peu au milieu
faire un trou au lieu d'en faire
plusieurs non récurrents histoire que
l'air et puisse sortir et que ça fasse
pas des des cloques sur la sur la pâte
et on va leur fournir 170 degrés
pendant à peu près 25 30 minutes
au bout d'à peu près une demi heure on
voit on a un fond de tarte qui est bien
doré bien cuit on va le sortir on va
laisser refroidir et on va le démouler
alors ensuite on va passer sur la crème
pâtissière pour faire une bonne crème
pâtissière il faut de la crème des
gousses de vanille fraîche une feuille
de gélatine que j'ai faites tremper dans
l'eau froide de la fécule de pomme de
terre ou de la maïzena du beurre des
jaunes et du sucre donc on va commencer
par faire chauffer doucement la crème je
vais couper mais vanille en deux on va
vraiment se mettre au milieu on va bien
la couper en deux pour la séparer et
ensuite on va venir gratter
l'intérieur
alors
on va les mettre dans la crème
et je veux aussi rajouter
la gauche
voilà on va porter la crème à ébullition
et on va laisser infuser pendant 20
minutes
hors du feu dans un récipient on va
mettre la fécule
le sucre
revenir mélanger et on va ajouter de
dans
le jaune
je vais verser un tout petit peu de
crème sur mon premier mélange
histoire de le déléguer un petit peu
et maintenant on va passer entièrement
dans la casserole
canton vert se mélangent comme ça
contient d eux ça va cuire assez
rapidement voilà maintenant on remet sur
le sueur sur la plaque à induction
et comme il ya la fécule de dans les eux
savent accueillir et ça va épaissir
et on va voir le changement assez assez
radicale de la crémière très rapidement
la vue elle se transforme en cette crème
assez épaisse
il faut surtout pas laisser en place
sinon ça va brûler dans le fond de la
casserole voilà l'idée c'est de une fois
qu'on est à ce point là c'est de la
faire cuire une minute pas plus pour
vraiment qu'elle soit parfaitement cuite
on va on va essorez la feuille de
gélatine qui a trompé pendant à peu près
20 minutes dans l'eau bien froide on va
la mettre directement dans la crème et
je vais en même temps rajouter mon
beurre et on va arrêter la cuisson la
crème comme ça on va mélanger
voilà on me l'a débarrassé dans un bol
et la faire refroidir assez rapidement
au frigo
on peut voir qu'on a déjà une crème
pâtissière une bonne crème pâtissière
bien vanier voilà maintenant on va
attaquer le caramel et le cuisson et la
cuisson de la pomme donc là on a besoin
simplement de sucre dos une pincée de
fleur de sel
la fève de tonka et des pommes pour
commencer on va réaliser
un caramel à sec pour commencer un
caramel à sec à la maison on va prendre
du coup sa casserole et on va verser un
fonds de sucre dans la casserole
vraiment pour pouvoir toujours avoir le
contrôle du moment où il va commencer à
caraméliser si on verserait toute la
quantité de sucre dans la casserole vous
verrez pas le fond est souvent c'est
comme ça qu'on brûle un caramel on a là
le caramel qui est bien cuit on voit il
commence à mousser un peu on le pousse à
c'est fort quand même une belle couleur
bien caramel on a de l'eau bouillante et
on va des glaces et le caramel avec cet
os
[Musique]
dans la casserole il fait noir et voilà
on est un petit caramel qui est quand
même assez liquide donc maintenant on va
éplucher nos pommes on va les découper
la pomme en dea en petits dés d'à peu
près un vilain 1 cm 1 cm et demi alors
ensuite on va mettre nos pommes dans un
mois j'ai un bac en inox mais on peut
très bien mettre un pyrex en verre sur
laquelle on peut mettre un couvercle
vient mettre les pommes à l'intérieur
dessus je parsemer de fleur de sel
à une fois qu'on a nos pommes dans dans
le bac on va verser le caramel qu'on a
réalisé juste avant quasiment à hauteur
hauteur des pommes pour finir pour
l'assaisonner on va rapper cette fameuse
fève de tonka
on va couvrir ça
et ça on va mettre au four à peu près à
140° pendant une heure mais de temps en
temps il faudra regarder la cuisson des
pommes elles vont cuire et vont
confirmer en fait elles vont absorber
tout le caramel qui à l'intérieur et
l'on comprend deux couleurs vraiment
très foncé alors là on a tous qui est
prêt notre crème qui a refroidi on a les
pommes qu'on peut voir elles sont bien
confie bien translucide on les a laissé
refroidir
on a récupéré un jus ce que j'appelle le
jus de cuisson des pommes donc ce
caramel qui si vraiment qu'on a récupéré
après après avoir cuit on a les fonds de
tarte alors je vais être au fond de la
tarte un peu de crème pâtissière je vais
venir prendre mes pommes
à venir garnir
garnir le fond de tarte
voilà j'essaie de ne pas abîmer cube sa
phase très joli et pas compotée on va
garder ces morceaux
très gourmand ensuite pour finir
on prend du nappage neutre et on va le
mélanger avec ce jus de cuisson
donc ce caramel qui a pris le goût de
pomme et de fève de tonka et après
délicatement avec un pinceau on va venir
napper les pommes pour apporter un peu
de brillance et pour finir à l'aide
d'une petite poche si on en a quand on
prend cette crème qu'on a mis en dessous
ça va porter ces petits bijoux cette
couche de gourmandise et on va venir
mettre des petits points voilà donc au
bout d'une petite pâte sucrée une crème
et ses pommes bien qu'armés lisez bien
cuites dans l'eure dans leur caramel un
outil à une petite tarte avec un fond
bien croustillant donc ce que je vous
disais un peu au début la particularité
de cette date 1 c'est d'avoir les pommes
cuites aussi dans un caramel mais d'être
dans une sur une pâte sucrée bien
croustillantes et avec cette gourmandise
ans ou de crème pâtissière donc tout ce
qu'il faut pour passer un super dessert
en europe
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse aujourd'hui au
chiffre 13 donc je redoute aujourd'hui
encore le chiffre 13 si on veut remonter
à l'origine de cette superstition il
faut remonter au christ avant il
n'existait pas la peur du chiffre 13
pourquoi le chiffre 13 parce que lorsque
judas devait désigner jésus que personne
ne connaissait il est allée l'embrasser
à la scène et quand il s'est assis à
table il était le 13e invités
on sait que par la suite il a pris de
remords il est allé se pendre donc de là
le chiffre 13 porte malheur et on va le
retrouver dans toute la tradition
chrétienne
alors aujourd'hui
là encore des gens qui font attention de
ne pas inviter 13 personnes lors d'un
dîner parce que toujours avec cette
connotation de porte malheur donc une
maîtresse de maison elle va inviter 12
ou 14 personnes si jamais pendant le
l'apéritif que l'on sert avant
la maîtresse de maison se rend compte
que quelqu'un est venu accompagné donc
de 12 ils sont passés à 13 il faudrait
vite qu'elle va vite un quatrième sinon
les gens vont se sentir mal et alors on
dit aussi que dans l'assemblée si
quelqu'un de superstitieux et là il va
s'en aller de lui même parce qu'il se
rend compte qu'il est le 13e et vie il
prend ses bagages et il s'en va oui
alors le chiffre 13 pour nous est censé
porter malheur alors que dans la kabbale
c'est un chiffre porte-bonheur
donc selon ses croyances on va dire où
ça x
13 peut porter bonheur ou malheur 13
porte malheur mais en revanche ce qui
porte malheur peut devenir porte bonheur
si on souhaite un étudiant je te dis
merde à la puissance 13 là c'est
totalement bénéfique d'une part par la
crotte de dollars et la puissance très
saine les angloys zone europe c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui merci aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
de bruxelles vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv soixante dix
huit rendez vous la semaine prochaine
très bonne soirée
sonos robe sur sensations
sont europe
[Musique]